i'm joined now by um lieutenant general
h.r mcmaster who's a former u.s national
security adviser and also author of
battlegrounds the fight to defend the
free world good evening and thank you
very much for being with us and i just
thought first of all this doesn't seem
to be going terribly well for vladimir
putin do you think he has badly
miscalculated here
mark it's a pleasure to be with you and
thanks for the reporting you're doing
from ukraine you know i i think he's
failed already i mean if his goals were
as reported
to subjugate all of ukraine to do it
quickly to do it without much of a fight
to think that ukrainians leaders were
going to flee to think that the
ukrainian people wouldn't fight
courageously as we've seen them fight
then yes he was completely wrong and i
think he underestimated ukrainians and
and i think it's pretty clear he
overestimated the capability of his own
military now that's not to say that of
course as you know all too well mark
that the ukrainian people aren't burying
the brunt of this that they aren't
suffering tremendously from from what
russia's how russia's adapted to that
failure uh which is to inflict more and
more casualties on the ukrainian people
to target the civilian populations with
these this indiscriminate bombing and
use of artillery and rockets
yeah i mean that's undoubtedly true but
what about putin do you think he seems
to be isolated he seems to have no one
that is able to talk to him or at least
willing to tell him the truth i mean how
dangerous do you think putin's state of
mind might be
i think it's hard it's already clear
that it's dangerous right but it's not
new that putin is dangerous right he's
been a murderer he's you know he's
murdered journalists he's tried to
assassinate with banned nerve agents a
political opponent a former kgb agent in
salisbury as you know all too well he's
enabled the serial episodes of mass
homicide which are the syrian civil war
he invaded
georgia in 2008. so he invaded ukraine
in 2014. so you know it's not as if this
is an aberrational uh
event uh but of course he's become
increasingly dangerous i think uh mark
because you know of these assumptions
that he's made he assumed that the west
was weak he assumed that ukraine
wouldn't fight and i think what he's
finding is the assumptions on which he
based his decisions were quite work or
were quite inaccurate he and i would add
xi jinping into that you know his best
friend self-declared for both of them
best friends uh and the 5 000 word
statement they issued just before the
olympics uh and the phone call they had
24 hours before uh you know before putin
inflicted these horrors on ukrainian
people
do you think his senior generals go
along with what he's doing here or do
you think
i mean is it time someone in the kremlin
took him out
well you know it's time for a change
right i mean he's dragging the russian
people down too
and so you would hope that the russian
people and you've seen the protests but
of course they haven't been able to
coalesce because they've been put down
brutally inside of russia but you know
vladimir putin loves to appear strong
doesn't he like he likes to ride a horse
you know shirtless on horseback but you
know what he's he's not very strong
right now i don't think mark i mean you
have to realize obviously that there are
more political prisoners in russia today
than there were during the height of the
of the cold war you know that there are
more people in russia's internal
security services than there are in
russia's military so you know those
aren't signs of strength i don't think
now i i don't understand what's going on
inside the kremlin i don't think anybody
does but we can only hope that there
would be a change of leadership and
maybe even leadership who recognized
that the future of the russian people
lies with europe right lies with peace
and the prosperity that that the russian
people could experience you know if they
if they put down the sword you know and
instead uh and instead focused on their
own future
do you think uh general that uh nato
may eventually be drawn into this war
i think it's a very strong possibility
mark you know i mean i i i think that
the chance for a broader war in europe
uh is significant
and and you know we're talking a lot
about the the aerospace domain and the
need to challenge it in the maritime
domains but of course this war is
already affecting all the neighboring
countries with you know the massive
refugee flow and the estimates are that
that could that could that could grow to
10 million people so i i think you know
markets already a broader war right
these wars as you know they don't stop
at boundaries the syrian civil war
didn't stop at syria's boundary and so i
think we have to recognize that the
chances of you know of an expansion of
the conflict are are quite high and you
know of course putin's been aggressive
you know beyond you know beyond ukraine
right he's as i mentioned he's invaded
georgia but he's also weaponized
refugees on poland's border he's in
encouraging serbian separatist movements
in in the balkans right he's he's
conducted massive cyber attacks so i i
think that you know that we have to be
prepared you know for for for an
expansion of this war we ought to try to
do everything we can to avoid it we have
to do everything
also to ensure that russia fails in
ukraine because if he succeeds there
it's not the end
yeah it's interesting you say that we
should do everything we can to avoid it
but we've just while you were speaking
there had pictures on the screen
general of all the hundreds of thousands
of people fleeing the country the
desperate images of families torn apart
is there at all a moral humanitarian
case
for actually getting involved now and
doing something
absolutely and and i think that we have
to obviously demonstrate that we have
the will and the capability to do so to
impose what some people are recommending
right safe safe zones and humanitarian
quarters but also we have to pull out
all the stops on providing the
ukrainians with the defensive
capabilities they need now there's a lot
of talk about mig fighters okay do it
how about medium range air defense
weapons how about more drone
capabilities because as the russians
pull their artillery and their rockets
into these bastions that they want to
use to rubble european cities hey we
have to help the ukrainians do something
about that but also we have to really
raise our voices loudly across the free
world uh for the establishment of a safe
maritime corridor to odessa for example
and and so i i really think that that
the time is now to pull out really all
the stops and i know that you've been
reporting you know on on what could
happen in the hydrocarbon sector if
there are sanctions but hey i think we
all have to be prepared to pay some
price to help the ukrainians who are
paying you know the ultimate price sadly
right now and and uh and and to
interrupt
the cash flows to putin that's on his
warming
right just finally because we've run out
of time but you're saying that we should
impose a no-fly zone and some sort of
maritime zone as well is that what
you're saying
we have to be quite transparent about
this with the russians right and we have
to we have to build the capability to do
it i think we'll have to tell them that
it's our intention unless he stops the
mass homicide in ukraine uh that we're
gonna have to act uh and and so i the
alternative mark i know i know of course
there's a tremendous risk of action we
always focus on that and quite rightly
but there there's a cost of inaction too
and i think we're seeing that now are we
going to watch what some estimates are
that a million people will will be
murdered uh by russian forces as he
continues to bombard these cities
but he said if anybody interfered
interfered that they would face and i'm
quoting here consequences that you have
never encountered in your history
well it's it's a not veiled threat right
of nuclear war but what is putin left
with right he has you know he has
economy that's in shambles his military
can't fight effectively they can bombard
innocent civilians but they can't fight
effectively so what is he left with he's
left with a cyber threat and he's left
with a nuclear threat of course we have
to take this seriously but i don't think
we we ought to to use his threats as an
excuse for inaction right we have to
take responsible action we have to act
together we have to generate the will
um and we have to be quite clear uh to
putin that what our intentions are you
know and and uh and of course none of
this the war right now is is not without
risk right ask the ukrainians who i know
you are asking them and you're you're
with them now
yeah well listen uh general mcmaster
very interesting stuff thank you very
much for being with us this evening
thank you mark